the fans have always been great and and
i'm looking forward to
to getting back out here you know seeing
some fans in the stands and just
enjoying it
good to see you good good yeah man
you'll be back soon hopefully good baby
good to see you be good it's tough to
see another uniform bud yeah i know hey
you got good pants though no probably a
little tight
i got your legs
i'll rock them back
all right
no no no no don't do that no no come on
bro
you messed up still getting picked on
several connections with this series
between the blue jays and astros but
none more tight than the one george
springer has
with his former teammates here in
houston jose or keady celebrated his
26th birthday with one of his best
outings of his career his last time out
that was at tropicana field against the
rays he beat him three to one tossing
seven shutout innings five strikeouts a
walk marcus simeon leading off again for
the blue chase with springer on the il
simeon coming off a terrific series out
in oakland
and a swing and a miss he strikes out
simeon on three pitches beau had a good
day yesterday as well three for four
drool walks stole a couple of bases made
a very good defensive play
he gets into one to left field and it is
headed for the crawford boxes and gone
beau bashed with number eight on the
season and the blue jays take an early
one to nothing lead we can say that
boba shed
might be the blue jays best hitter he
doesn't give any ground he keeps that
front shoulder locked right in on that
baseball and he's able to lift it out of
this ballpark on a line watch this thing
ricochet above those seats
lady was one of the few blue jays who
was not in on the hit parade yesterday
really one of two they had 16 hits
and that's hit well to right racing in
and toward the line tucker long run and
he makes the catch and then goes into
the slide
nicely done by kyle tucker just in fair
territory for the second out i don't
think initially tucker knew exactly how
hard guerrero hit it this ball slicing
away from him down that right field line
had to come in and over luckily knows
this ballpark well
ross came off the injured list to make
his first start in three weeks with a
nice outing versus atlanta pitched into
the fifth inning allowing five hits two
runs he ran his pitch count up to 70
losing steam in that fifth inning
that ball softly hit into left field
holds up for loris guriel yuli's younger
brother makes the play and there's two
outs julie with a base hit now here's
carlos correa one strike pitch
and that's hammered deep down the left
field line hooking if it stays fair it's
gone and it hits off the foul pole
two-run home run carlos correa and it's
2-1 astros welcome home cc that ball
started down the line i wasn't sure if
it was going to be able to stay fair but
it didn't hook too much carlos correa
young early early in his career showed
us that he can take the fastball inside
and keep it fair he did such a great job
of staying inside like yuli but able to
get the head out and snap it so the
bases are loaded for bregman who singled
his first time up on a 3-2 pitch
bregman's ready so is stripling 3-2
inside ball four miss with a fastball
maldonado comes home and the astros lead
it 3-1 on the bases loaded walk to
bregman
with the bases full and two out to two
breaking ball strike three call on the
outside corner alvarez thought it was
off the plate away statcast agrees with
him
but he goes down looking to in the
inning but the astros bat around and
score three times to take the lead danny
with his first home run of the season
yesterday a two-run shot back in oakland
and jansen got a fastball in on his
hands sends a fly ball to left field
bradley turning watching and it's gone a
minute made park home run into the
crawford boxes just barely but barely is
good enough as jansen hits his second in
his many days same type of pitch that he
hit the home run in oakland that he hit
that one tonight here in houston a big
smile on his face as he heads back home
it's a high fastball and he's able to
get to it maldonado just looks more
confident at the plate now doesn't he
yeah he does obviously having a little
bit of success he started and stopped
and maldonado pops one way up in the air
vladimir guerrero jr right near the foul
line stays with it and now backs into
mile straw
that would have been an interesting
double play yeah had to show some strong
legs there supporting the weight of
guerrero jr again this win moving that
baseball around glad junior stays with
it has to use miles straw the human
backstop
straw being held on by guerrero not
going
and a ground ball back to the mound nice
play by meza under hands it on to
guerrero
and that'll take care of brantley and
the astros alvarez at first with one out
for julie guriel who's two for two
couple of singles and a run three two
ariel lines it deep to left center it
sends back guriel looking up see you
later
julie guriel with a two run homer and
the astros lead grows it's five to two
sent that baseball right over his
brother's head just like they're in the
backyard gets himself another one right
here with a rocket off the bat at 100
miles an hour on a line into the
crawford boxes la liga
a three for three night now you gotta
show us the flow julie yeah that's right
once you've done the celebration he has
always hit well in this ballpark that's
his 44th home run that he has hit here
in this ballpark
lines it to first and what a play by
vlady who is having some kind of a night
defensively so the blue jays already
down by three tyson a jam here in the
sixth inning against michael brantley
the o2
brantley lines it to left field the
catch made by goriel here comes straw
here comes the throw and he got him a
flat footed throw from left all the way
to the plate to get straw
what a play
here's guerrielle man he's he's killing
it he's three for three julie up the
middle base hit bregman being waved
around he's gonna score yuli guriel
another rbi it's a six to two game he is
four for four newly with another
incredible night here's the 1-0
rips this one left center field and deep
going back on it grichik and it's going
to be a one-hopper off the wall
alvarez will score the whole guriel at
third on the rbi double by tucker it's
7-2
you're going to get your first five-hit
game you might as well do it in front of
family another brother lourdes out in
left field
in the air down the right field line
here comes tay oscar i think he caught
that ball he did boy what a nice play by
hernandez bregman
alertly will tag and score and come in
on the play to make it ten to two but a
really good play by tay oscar hernandez
for the second hour and with it being
exact flying stays perfect
tay oscar hernandez stands in over three
oscar hernandez sends one to right and
it's gone boy that one carried
over the outstretched glove of tucker
into the second row of seats and that'll
be a two-run homer for hernandez to make
it 10-4
now the crowd
25 thousand 4-10 tonight inside mid-may
park
there's sense in this game
it's about to be over ready for some
friday night fireworks two outs two
strikes astros up big
into center field on come straw miles
will get there and put it away for the
final out
ball game over astros win the first game
of this home stand